we played yesterday James O'Keefe's
excellent expose of an executive at
Pfizer confiding in someone he that he
thought he was on a romantic date with
that don't tell the public but Pfizer is
secretly performing gain of function
research to beef up viruses to work on
on new Pharmaceuticals and the date says
well what Pfizer is working on gain of
function research and the exec says yeah
I mean we don't tell the public that but
we are working on that and then
just yesterday James O'Keefe releases
the footage of when he walks out like
Chris Hansen comes in sits down he says
hey hey I think I'm gonna have a seat
over here what are you do you work for
Pfizer did you we've got you on camera
admitting to and
things go awry
hey there is your seat taken you work
for Pfizer my question for you is why is
Pfizer want to hide from the public the
fact that they're mutating the covet
viruses is this real life I'm literally
a liar I was trying to impress a person
on a date
don't touch me well this is not why the
way don't tell anybody he was just
working in a company
you really did please
can you please unlock your door no no
don't let them leave you please unlock
the door
please unlock please unlock the door
please unlock the door
lock the door
unlock the door
that is the the director of worldwide r
d uh specifically on mRNA strategic
planning that those are the people
who are behind the the fouchy ouchy that
that has now gone into the arms of five
and a half billion people worldwide this
lunatic who's out on on what he thinks
is this date and then he he just loses
it starts getting violent running around
oh my gosh is this real life oh my gosh
and then what's his excuse
this is my favorite part
the minute James I keep says hey we just
got you on camera admitting that
Pfizer's doing ain't a function research
he goes I'm a liar
that's his excuse I'm a liar I was lying
and that's always what these guys do
this was just a modern day version of To
Catch a Predator the Chris Hansen the
show that would get pedophiles this is
just that hey why don't you what are you
doing here
don't you have a seat over there what
are you doing here
and instantly what happens all the time
the guys on the To Catch a Predator show
who want to sleep with underage girls
they say oh I wasn't doing anything no I
didn't I didn't come here to have sex I
didn't know not at all I was just I was
just lying in the chat oh no all those
logs you have of me talking to this girl
about how I was going to come over and
drive 12 hours and sleep with I was just
lying it's the same excuse from the
Pfizer exec no I was just lying well the
problem with that excuse is if you are a
liar if your best defense is that you
are a liar then obviously I can't
believe you now
and it's not just this Pfizer exec this
was fauci's excuse do you remember fauci
initially said when kovid broke out
and the Liberals at that time were
downplaying it before they started
overplaying it fauci said there's no
reason to wear a mask
there is no reason when the virus is
spreading around for you to wear a mask
out in public do not wear a mask and
then five seconds later he says you have
to wear a mask everywhere all the time
wearing like three of them
what changed fauci admitted how he
changed his mind
or or changed his rhetoric because he
didn't change his mind he said oh yeah
when I told you you didn't need to wear
a mask I thought there'd be a shortage
and I wanted to save them for my friends
but then I found out there was an issue
so I told you to wear them so fauci's
excuse was the same excuse as the Pfizer
exec was the same excuse as the pedos On
To Catch a Predator
I'm a liar I'm a liar don't believe
anything we say okay
all right guys if that's what you want
I'll I'll take your word for it I have
no doubt that you guys are big Liars
speaking of
virality and and social media
big news I meant to get to it yesterday
we didn't have time
president kofefe
El Donaldo himself
is back on Facebook
meta which is the parent company now for
Facebook and Instagram and all the rest
of it
they've announced
quote we are bringing Mr Trump back in
the coming weeks with certain guard
rails applicable to any public figures
suspended for certain violations during
times of civil unrest
the penalties and potential restrictions
that we've put in place are a deterrent
and Trump could face another suspension
if he keeps breaking the rules
why are they letting Trump back
it's been years at this point
it's been two years
why does he get to come back now Elon
put him back on Twitter
even though Trump isn't using his
Twitter yet probably because he has
contractual obligations with truth
social
but Elon put him back on
so maybe that puts a little pressure on
Facebook Trump is now a declared
candidate for the presidency I think
that probably puts a little pressure on
Facebook but but
probably the biggest Factor here
is that the January 6th The Narrative
fell apart
the reason that Trump was banned from
social media the reason that these
oligarchs in Silicon Valley who work
with but not totally through the
government they're this awful Blobby
public-private kind of partnership that
does the bidding of the government the
government's Dirty Work they can't do
for itself but also is completely
unaccountable to the people
the whole argument for Banning Trump was
that this guy led a violent insurrection
a near coup d'etat on January 6th and
that didn't happen
we know
because we've had two years of
Investigations into this
they told us Trump
incited the Insurrection well we have
the video Trump says be peaceful be
peaceful don't be violent go home
okay there goes that one well
nevertheless the the followers of Donald
Trump they were they were so violent
they killed people they killed police
officers that's not true the only person
who was killed in political violence on
January 6th was Ashley Babbitt she was a
trump supporter in the capital shot by a
trigger happy cop
well what about officer Brian sicknick
officer Brian sicknick died of natural
causes
after the January 6th Riot he did not
die in any violence on January 6 nor did
any other cop
well
they nevertheless even if they didn't
kill anybody even if they weren't
particularly violent even if Donald
Trump never incited anything they they
were still leading an Insurrection okay
then how come none of them were charged
with insurrection
how come they were charged with
trespassing
I mean the prosecutors threw the book at
these people they threw them in solitary
confinement for long periods of time
but they couldn't they couldn't get a
charge of insurrection because it didn't
happen
so the whole thing just it just fell
apart
a whole thing fell apart so now they let
Trump back on I think there is one
ulterior motive here beyond that that
the the libs couldn't quite withstand
the pressure of of still with a straight
face saying that Trump couldn't be on
Facebook the I think the other ulterior
motive is the libs want a bloody GOP
Primary and the thinking
back when they were trying to keep Trump
off the ballot in certain places back
when they were trying to throw Trump in
prison I guess they're still trying to
do that back when they were keeping him
totally ostracized from social media the
the prevailing view was that Donald
Trump if he ran for president 2024 would
clear the Republican field so there
would be no Challengers he would be the
nominee automatically
and so the libs were throwing everything
they had at him that no longer appears
to be the case Ron DeSantis among others
seems to be building a pretty strong
campaign for president
it's still Trump's race to lose Trump is
still way up in the polls but DeSantis
is posing a real challenge to Trump
right now
other people are saying they'll run too
Mike Pence is saying he's very
interested in running Nikki Haley says
she's very interested in running Tim
Scott says he's very interested in
running so it just no matter what you
think of those people or Trump trump did
not clear the field and so now the lib
strategy has to switch and they're going
to want a more bloody GOP Primary which
means they're probably going to be much
more interested in allowing Donald Trump
to be on platforms such as Facebook in
fact you saw a similar principle
just a couple of days ago
with with the azov Battalion in Ukraine
for years the azov Battalion which is
filled with neo-nazis in Ukraine was
banned from Facebook why because it's
filled with neo-nazis
but now Facebook is on the side of
Ukraine fighting against Russia
and so the enemy of my enemy is my
friend and the azov Battalion is one of
the most powerful regiments in the
Ukrainian military
and so Facebook says okay never mind
they're not Nazis anymore or even if
they are they're they're like the good
Nazis okay we're going to let them back
on Facebook the rest of the show
continues now we've got a lot it's fake
headline Friday I need your help in in
sussing out which are the four real
headlines which is the fake headline and
also
buddy of mine is coming on the show very
briefly to talk about his new movie it's
coming out because Greg Perot is the
star of the new Left Behind movie and
Greg Perot
he's got a lot of great credits so I'll
wait until the member block but head on
over the movie uh premieres this weekend
it's going to be a huge Smash If you're
not a member already go to dailywire.com
for two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign